this crowd is protesting after 20 days
waiting for food assistance it's hard to
make out her shouts in dialect but her
desperation is clear
the Mafia exploit the vulnerable in
times of crisis reports it's happening
already in the same region of Campania a
local politician took this video of a
post-office queue it may appear normal
but a self-appointed security guard is
demanding money from people at the door
Rocco Rawat olam lost his construction
company to the Mafia in the last
financial crash it later led to this
raid after Rocco infiltrated the Kimura
gang resulting in the arrest of 29
members mobsters who'd offered help with
cash flow then seized control and the
poor are growing more vulnerable food
banks have seen a 40% increase in people
across the country needing help and the
biggest demand is in the south where
poverty is rife 3.7 million Italians
work in the black economy their income
not backed by any government scheme so
they need help
400 million euros has been allocated to
food assistance billions more to helping
businesses but red tape in Italy means
that help could come too late and the
Mafia could be there sooner
in companies' capital maples reports the
Camorra gang is giving food to people
who've lost their jobs and cash to
struggling businesses one in two shops
here now at risk of bankruptcy former
prosecutor and mayor of naples says
they've so far prevented what he calls a
criminal infection but warns the Mafia
is always ready to exploit those in need
[Music]
the funeral of the brother of a former
mafia boss in Sicily earlier this month
shows a crowd flouting lockdown rules
certainly suggesting a sense of
confidence from a crime gang who knows
who's in control Sally Oakwood sky
newsroom